i don't like that ben shapiro well i
don't like ben shapiro but
i don't like the pen shapiro's trying to
own the meme about him
so ben shapiro made this video a couple
days ago ben shapiro destroys a
thanksgiving turkey with facts and logic
have you seen this video i've heard of
it i have not seen it yet though
it's pretty good mike
yes i know this video is a day late but
it's important because today
is black friday which means that our
black friday deal
is back that's right get 50 off a daily
wire membership with code dw50
head over to the daily wireless
subscribe or click the link in the
description
below of course producer colton is
forcing me to cook a turkey
damn it now before we jump in before i
put on an apron
oh that was funny i don't like when ben
shapiro tries to act human
like say what you want about mark
zuckerberg and i don't like mark
zuckerberg but at least mark zuckerberg
embraces the fact that he's a robot
yeah no you're right yeah he just that's
it because he is a robot
but human is [ __ ] the worst and you
know every one of these
ideas is somebody else's idea like it's
probably his wife like oh yeah embrace
it be quirky
and it just looks robotic when he does
it cfon goes nothing is more uncool than
brent shapiro trying to be cool
expected this video okay sponsored by
ray ken all right let's
get cooking all right here we go okay
i'm sorry but did he do this on purpose
look what he did tell me he didn't do
this on purpose
by raikkonen all right let's get cooking
watch all right here we go
he always on purpose it's a natural
instinct
i'm gonna cook this monstrous thing
first let's make sure it's dead
that's the first step oh my god he
really is trying to be funny
he's not okay
now we're gonna preheat the oven to 425
degrees
i feel like that you need a higher
temperature okay rinse the turkey and
pat dry
this thing's larger is somebody wearing
a mask in his house all right
i feel like oh and the cameraman are
wearing masks inside his house
how you like that if we had somebody
filming
in here i know i'd be like take those
off i'll [ __ ] throw you out the
window yeah we don't need those thank
you
[ __ ] do not do that [ __ ] joey from
friends i'm gonna end up with this thing
on my head
although oh he likes friends i just okay
it started to make sense
knowing ben though he's just neurotic
about money
and why would you say that and legal
stuff so i guarantee you
he doesn't even care he's having him
wear the masks in case any of
because you know he's neurotic enough to
go but whatever him gets covered and
then they sue me and they say that i
didn't have masks when i was having the
i guarantee you it's all to cover ben's
ass i bet you he's not scared of covid
he's scared of somebody getting covered
and having footage of them being in his
house without a mask and being like i
got it at ben shapiro's house
he's having none of that [ __ ] he's like
put a mask on and take your shoes off
here we go turkeys are weird because
they have a strangely humanoid aspect to
them
yeah turkeys sure do don't they
can i can i be honest here no
that does that seem like kind of a [ __ ]
kitchen for ben shapiro to have
no the kitchen's nice enough it's a nice
no the size of the kit
remember for california that's a nicely
sized kitchen
well i don't even mean the size like
even just the balance all right it just
doesn't like for ben shapiro and his
doctor wife you'd think
his wife's a doctor and dude and also he
comes from money
his family was like hollywood lawyers
and [ __ ]
his cousin is [ __ ] matilda um
whatever her name is mara wilson or
whatever so his whole family's loaded so
yeah i don't know i think that is a
shitty
somebody says do you know ben is now a
florida resident did ben shapiro really
move to florida
no no there's no way please no
ben lives in florida now no no are you
[ __ ] syria
no people are saying he lives in texas
more than one person saying florida he
moved maybe that's a rental
oh no he didn't come here did he
oh no i'll take most of these jews in
florida i don't care but not ben
he moved to south florida he must be in
palm beach
ben shapiro moved to south florida all
right i got an
idea we go [ __ ] with ben shapiro but
here's how we do it right
we don't want to get the anti-semite
label so we go [ __ ] with ben shapiro
we bring laurel loomer what the [ __ ] was
that oh my god
i want you to know i didn't see anything
he had it on his screen he had to pull
it up on the screen
i i [ __ ] i knew it i [ __ ]
so his company is based in nashville
but he lives in south florida
with robbie phillip moscow it's in rabbi
josh brody by the way somebody said he
probably moved in with gabe hoffman
yeah gabe probably needs a roommate he
probably lost a lot of money
continuously trying to short tesla
boy did that not work out huh
i'm trying to see by the way that's
always a good
solid investment strategy hey let me let
me short the tech company that's in bed
with the government
now the question is did he move to boca
raton or parkland because i'm just
trying to figure out what part of
florida he moved to
well it could be west ba anything in the
west palm
unless he's is he really in broward
county it's south florida
it says south florida so it doesn't say
warren stuff but he mentioned
apparently he mentioned this in this
interview that he moved to south florida
so yeah so his company's in nashville
but he's going to be living in south
florida that makes no sense
i'm on the bench apparel reddit super
excited to have ben shapiro join us in
florida if i saw him on the public i
would definitely buy him a beer or
whatever
south florida then most likely moved to
north miami beach or hollywood those are
yes
you definitely buy ben shapiro beer
does he even drink beer
ben i think if you offered him a beer he
would hiss and run away like a possum
the daily wire conservative media
company started by ben shapiro and
jeffrey boring
and caleb robinson plans to move its
headquarters from los angeles to
nashville
uh the publisher and 75 employees based
in los angeles are being given until
october 1st to decide
whether to make the move boehring says
he said it looks about 80
would make the move uh so yeah so
the company's moving to nashville i
guarantee he's not commuting to
nashville
telecommuting probably doing a show
remotely
well i will say this jeremy boring more
like
jeremy boring
i got him that's pretty good well it's
spelled differently
the joke works better on twitter
i want to stab you
[Laughter]
kind of walking around carrying what was
once alive
it's gruesome and horrifying all right
and i'm supposed to pat this dry
like with a cloth as a hillary clinton
joke guys all right
he's such a [ __ ] nerd and i don't
even understand ben you make enough
money what is this [ __ ] weird
like at night trying to do a comedy
sketch but the extent of this sketch
should be here's how to make a
thanksgiving dinner
hey i make millions of dollars make a
turkey
i'm gonna go watch football there's
something
weird about men making like the like
most of the thanksgiving dinner yeah
like it's one thing to do the bird and
some guys do the meat and stuff but like
you know it's it's weird to see guys
doing the whole meal it's like i don't
know it's always been kind of the women
the women should to to season the turkey
and then if you're doing the deep fry
they meant you put it in the deep fryer
because that's a man job outside so you
want
you don't want them to burn the house
down yeah it's the women cook and they
do all that stuff and the men drink and
watch football and embarrass the family
by fist fighting
right isn't it all famous or not the
purpose of that was
was this thing like dropped in a bat of
urine before and now it's all clean or
what
oh facts i tell you folks i was the
funniest kid
in orthodox jewish cool everybody told
me why is he washing the meat is he
black
i don't know because i feel like that's
insufficient like should i wash it with
soap like
what should i have done here i always
watch it because you know how my homies
roll
in any case an inspiring inspiring
performance here
create your compound butter by mixing
the room temperature butter freshly
chopped herbs what's the point of this
i don't know i i don't know
because it's like there's a lot of look
ben does it a lot of these people do it
right
about like they they film these mundane
but now moments in their lives and they
think because they're famous
you guys give a [ __ ] and i've always
hated that i've always hated people that
operate under that assumption
that's why honestly there's so much irl
streaming that i hate
because people think that like there's
actually people that want to watch you
stop at a mcdonald's and eat and nobody
wants to watch that that's boring
i understand filming [ __ ] when shit's
going down or filming something that's
interesting
but there's a lot of these people now
that are like i'm gonna film
me making a turkey and you're like oh do
you do a cooking channel normally no and
it's like then why
who gives a [ __ ] why does why does
somebody want to watch your favorite e
celeb make a [ __ ] turkey
i i guess like i see them do it and
there's times where like people even ask
me like hey you know
uh you're gonna like if i go oh i'm
going out to eboor or something
people like oh you're going to stream it
and i'm like i don't think anybody wants
to watch me have beers like that
you know what i mean like i don't
understand this mentality that fame like
some of these famous people have they're
like man i bet everybody would love to
make watch me make a turkey
but why though you're not you're not
really that exciting when you talk
well now he's stuffing the turkey in the
roasting pan and into the oven
now if you notice when i open up my oven
the walls of my oven are blue
did you see his joke no he missed the
mystical making a good idea
sorry you missed a good joke i know but
i was making a really good prussian blue
joke
this is solid japan and into the oven
the lion king i i you don't get the lion
king
in minecraft in minecraft
[Laughter]
behold this horrific turkey
doing it the rescue way i should be
wearing oven mitts while we wait
how about we uh say hi to one of our
sponsors
yeah but first give thanks
this is the first six minutes with two
live reads he's doing a live read for a
[ __ ] goofy turkey video that's
already a commercial but the good news
is at least i've now figured out why
he's doing this
now i figured i know exactly why this
video is being made
because ben shapiro sells more ad space
than he can actually do on his show i
i'm will i'm serious i'm i'll bet i will
bet you money
that ben shapiro oversells his
advertising spots
and that's why he does so many live
reads and that's why he's been doing all
these extra videos
he's got to deliver those ads one way or
another
that's it that's all this is he knows oh
well you know i could sell you 50 live
reads this month because i do that but
but you know what i could do
55 and i could do extra videos and he's
just working he's working in this
product
he's working in his live reads because
he's got to deliver him or he's got to
give the money back
this [ __ ] man
or raycons raycons are fantastic
there are many celebrities who use
raycons including me it may be the only
thing that cardi b and i have
in common other than both being platinum
award-winning rappers raycon you know
about the same height too
offers their wireless card like that are
super comfortable they come with a
variety of fit options
which makes it perfect to fit your ear
the compact carrying case
80 bucks for these shitty things i bet
they sound like garbage i bet you they
do
four times that's four one more than
three it's four
times on a single charge unlike some of
your other wireless options ray khan
earbuds are both stylish and discreet
nodes angling wires no stems they're
great
for video chats again unlike other
options they're not one size fits all
they come in variety of colors
i love my raycons and you will too
raycon here but start about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market they sound just as
amazing
as other top audio brands you know
raycons are great for working from home
working out listening to music and
podcasting get that shot
just organically use our neighbors crazy
these raycons are also excellent
for waiting for your turkey i love that
he gets the footage of like
where he's trying to look like he's just
naturally using it but that's very
clearly a moment where ben was in his
office
and they they mailed out the product and
then he went hey excuse me can you come
in here real quick grab my camera
we gotta get it tell me isn't it it's
just it's everything
about him is manufactured i hate him
slick babies these are the best model
yet six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass more compact
design that gives you
a nice noise isolating fit it also comes
in new fun colors click the link in the
description below
or go to buy raycon.com man i know we do
live reads and and
we do two we do two live reads in a in a
two-hour show for example right
i understand that and i have nothing
against um making money
make money that's the whole point of
this right
but to make a nine minute things little
fun thanksgiving video
and do a a full live read in it i mean
what is that
the live reads are actually taking up
most of this video yeah and it's
like yeah i have nothing against making
money and doing live reads but ben
shapiro
would stop a girl in the middle of a
[ __ ] to do a live read for [ __ ]
birch gold and i
like i don't you know what i mean like i
want to make money royce wants me we all
want to make some money and [ __ ] but
like
jesus christ get a [ __ ] grip dude
fifteen percent
off your order
see behold ether has a good point in the
chat he says eighty dollars for
seventeen
17
bluetooth earpods i guarantee if you go
on amazon right now especially this time
of year
and you look up wireless bluetooth
headphones i guarantee you you will find
a better deal
than this [ __ ] that ben is shilling i'll
bet you cash money if you go on amazon
right now there's probably a pair for
like 45
that are probably really [ __ ] good
and guess what you know what the best
part with amazon is
you don't have to worry about some shady
third-party company
not honoring their [ __ ] if it breaks
you'll get it replaced on amazon don't
worry
thank you god almighty above and thank
you to our producers for forcing me to
do this
horrifying video yeah they forced you
i'm sure the producers
wanted nothing more than to spend days
leading up to thanksgiving in at your
house instead of with their families
yeah i bet it was all their idea ben
one more library don't forget to check
out our black friday deal get 50
off a daily wear membership with code
three live reads in a nine minute video
nice nice